Speaker 1: got a ton of emails from people
saying, David, there is a new straw poll out
for Republicans in 2024 and Trump isn't winning.
You've got to talk about it.
So I'm going to talk about it.
But for better or worse, I don't know if this
will bring pleasure or disdain or a sadness
to people in the audience.
It's a pretty meaningless poll.
This is a poll from the Western Conservative
Summit.
And indeed, Republican Florida Governor Ronda
Santos won over Donald Trump in this straw
poll that was conducted on Saturday.
Now, let's look at the numbers.
This is a poll in which Ronda Santos came
in first with 74 percent.
Donald Trump was second with 71 percent.
Then you have Ted Cruz at 42 percent, Mike
Pompeo at 39 percent, and Tim Scott at 35
percent.
Now, why is this a meaningless poll result?
It's meaningless because this is number one.
It's a long time from now, first of all.
Number two, this is an approval poll.
So there are two things that make it meaningless
for us for identifying Trump's actual chances
in 2024.
Number one, it just asks you, do you approve
of Trump to Santos, whoever or not?
Do you support them in 2024 as the Republican
nominee?
And number two, you can vote yes.
Essentially, I approve for more than one person.
That's why it doesn't add up to 100 percent
to Santa 74, Trump 71.
So this tells us.
Very, very little about what's going to go
on in 2024, but I still think that there are
some interesting things to glean from this.
Why is it that DeSantis is doing well?
The Santurce is doing well because he is a
more competent and I believe far more dangerous
version of Trump's authoritarian lunacy.
In a sense, the Santurce is more Trump being
than Trump to the degree that he can better
communicate his harebrained ideas that he
shares with Donald Trump himself.
We've talked before about, you know, could
Donald Trump's presidency open the door to
an even dumber and even more incompetent version
of Trump that Republicans would vote for?
The answer is absolutely.
As I've said earlier and before, if you overstate
the intelligence of the Republican electorate,
you will be disappointed.
We thought in twenty, fifteen, twenty, sixteen,
OK, there's a lot of ignorant Republicans
who are easily tricked, but they're not going
to vote for Trump.
They're not this ignorant.
And then they did.
So could they vote for someone even worse
than Trump in terms of cartoonish incompetence?
Yes, but the risk about de Santurce is that
he's more competent than Donald Trump.
He's an authoritarian nut with delusions based
on supply side economic ideas and religious
conservatism and all this stuff.
But he is more competent than Trump.
He is more coherent in the presentation of
these bad ideas, and that has the potential
to make him far more dangerous than Donald
Trump actually is.
And that's a really, really scary thing.
So on the one hand, it's an approval poll.
You can say I approve of the Santurce and
I approve of Trump.
And so that makes it of limited value to us
right now for twenty twenty four.
It's also approval rather than who would you
vote for.
It's also still the first half of twenty twenty
one.
So there are limited things we can glean from
this.
But if I am to glean one thing here, it's
that Donald Trump's worst instincts are present
in Rhondda Santurce and packaged more competently
in terms of DeSantis, his delivery and quite
frankly, the Santas being from Florida, Florida.
We don't know what the map is going to look
like in 2020 for a lot of it will depend on
how does 2022 go and how much voter suppression
is there in many other things.
But there is no doubt that if Florida is important,
the Santurce, as the Republican nominee, could
play a very, very big role there as well.
So don't read too much into this.
But an interesting straw poll nonetheless.